meanwhile the Spanish newspaper El Pais
has published documents it says our
confidential letter sent by the U.S and
the NATO alliance to Russia the leak
documents detail the U.S and NATO's
formal response to a list of moscow's
Demands Chief among them that NATO rule
out admitting Ukraine to the security
Alliance they shed more light on the
high-stakes diplomacy taking place
behind the scenes including potential
nuclear disarmament and Trust building
agreements
and for more of this we can go over to
Terry Schultz who's reporting for us in
Brussels hi Terry so what stands out to
you from these leaked documents are
there any uh clear differences between
the U.S and NATO responses
hi Sumi uh the the first thing that
stood out to me was just how similar the
documents are to exactly what we were
told were in these letters both NATO
Secretary General stoltenberg and U.S
officials had given public statements
saying that this is how they responded
to Russia and I'm not saying I didn't
believe them but I'm still struck by
just how much we did know about what
these letters were and therefore why
they were kept classified the NATO
letter is just two pages long and quite
General while the U.S response is four
pages because the U.S has more details
with which to respond it has missiles
which NATO doesn't and Russia asked more
of the United States so the U.S letter
talks about what the U.S is willing to
do if Russia reciprocates including
going back to Arms Control agreements
that have fallen by the wayside limiting
and and being more transparent about
about troop movements which Russia does
not do I was also struck by sort of this
scolding nature in the U.S letter in
particular it reminded Russia that it
invaded Crimea and and illegally annexed
it that it has troops in Ukraine in the
eastern Ukraine which Russia denies and
also that it has troops still in Georgia
and in Moldova which were not there at
the invitation of those governments and
Terry tell us again how the Russian side
has responded to these letters
well besides what you heard from
President Putin that was reiterated
again in a letter from foreign minister
Sergey lavrov which was posted on the
Russian foreign Ministry website and it
it reiterates that Russia feels this
this zero-sum situation that any
reinforcement any reassurance sent to
its neighbors is uh destabilizing for
Russia so lavrov says once again that
the West does not understand the Russia
the Russian position and that without uh
if the these members members are allowed
to have NATO forces on their territory
that it is not acceptable to Russia this
is something where there is a clear
difference of opinion that simply I
don't see how it can be bridged so taken
together the letters and the response
from Russia does this do anything to
change the Diplomatic state of play in
this standoff
I don't think so again we've heard
everyone's positions publicly what it
does do is is show everyone in black and
white that what President Putin says
that the rush that the West basically
ignored Russia's uh Russia's proposals
and and Russia's concerns is not true
because the letters address very
specifically what Russia wants NATO and
the U.S to do and which are not
acceptable the other thing that I that I
find interesting is that now those
people in Eastern Europe who may have
feared that that NATO and the U.S might
be willing to compromise on their
security and withdraw some of these
forces and these reassurance measures
that's not on the table at all
DW's Terry Schultz in Brussels for us
thank you so much